military groups like Sierra Leone's
revolutionary united front
he also traces the history of the De
Beers diamond company in the book blood
diamonds tracing the deadly path of the
world's most precious stones this is a
little over an hour good evening on
behalf of the tattered cover it is my
pleasure to welcome you and to thank you
for supporting independent book selling
with blood diamonds tracing the path of
the world's most precious stones Greg
Campbell exposes the gruesome story of
diamond smuggling and its repercussions
that are felt far beyond the borders of
the poor war ridden and devastated
country of Sierra Leone quite often
these blood diamonds find their way into
the rings of Brides all over the world
at the starred Kirkus Reviews States
reader readers of Campbell's horrific
tale who don't demand proof of source on
any diamond purchase ought to have their
ethics examined Craig Campbell's an
award-winning journalist and author of
the road to Kosovo a balkan diary which
is also published by Westview press his
work has appeared in the San Francisco
Chronicle the Christian Science Monitor
and foreign policy magazine and he has
also contributed to the 5th edition of
Lonely Planet's West Africa guidebook we
are delighted that he's with with us
this evening at the Tattered Cover
please welcome from Longmont Colorado
Greg Campbell
thank you for seeing good evening thank
you very much for coming and really
happy to see so many people here I think
maybe if I can be indulged just for a
minute or two what I'd like to do is
start off just by reading just a couple
of paragraphs from the book just very
quickly I'm going to give you a kind of
a real brief rundown
I wrote blood diamonds tracing the
deadly path of the world's most precious
stones mainly as the reason one of the
many reasons that I did it was because
it's such an absolutely fascinating
story at its heart it's a war story but
it's also a business story and kind of
in a strange way it's also about the
continuing global reach of terrorism as
kind of apropos as we're here
coming up on the on the eve of September
11th so if I if I could I'm going to try
and tie those three things in just real
quickly by reading just a couple of
paragraphs because what we have it kind
of starts at the beginning on ground
level it's a war story as I said Sierra
Leone is a very small West African
country that's been at war for the last
ten years and what makes it notable
outside of the causes of the war which
we're going to get to in just a second
is the is the absolute brutality of the
tactics that were waged from all sides
in this conflict basically what you have
is the government of Sierra Leone a
legitimate democratic government that
achieved its independence from the crown
of England in 1961 and a ruthless band
of murderers there's pretty much no
better way to put it there should be a
much stronger way the revolutionary
united front
they are UF and those are the rebels
between the two there has never really
been an even fight it's always been the
ru F has been much better guns it's been
much better trained and the reason for
all that is because of its diamond
wealth it's used proceeds from stealing
diamonds literally out of the ground
from the government and selling them
into the mainstream channels of one of
the most unique commodities businesses
in the entire world whether one of the
strangest industries that exists today
and I'm sorry if I'm sending like them a
little bit excited I am this is like
it's such an incredible story I had so
much fun writing this book which is not
to say it's not to dilute one bit the
horrors of everything that I saw and
that continues to go on today so let me
read for you just for a couple quick
seconds it'll only take a couple of
minutes but I think this is going to
pretty much illustrate this these three
things we've got the war the brutality
of the war we've got the diamond
industry and we've got what to me is
like one of the most incredible links to
international terrorism and al Qaeda
so I'll just real quickly start here I'm
going to start in the prologue actually
and it's called impact the price of
diamonds
Ishmael dollar Army lost his hands in
1996 with two quick blows of an axe
he didn't or couldn't recall the pain of
the blows but he remembered being
ordered at gunpoint to place his wrists
on a wooden stump dripping with the
blood of his neighbors who were writhing
on the ground around him trying to stem
the flow of blood from their arms or
staggering away doll Rumi does recall
that it was quick and methodical the
victim in line in front of him was
swiftly kicked away and suddenly he
faced a bloody wooden block in an
impatient gang of heavily armed teens
eager to be done with their day's orders
he didn't fight his captors or beg for
mercy instead he removed a crude metal
ring made by his son from one of the
fingers on his left hand and put it in
his pocket one of the last acts his
hands performed for him and I'll skip to
the end the prologue like almost anyone
else who buys diamond rings or necklaces
I didn't realize that the small stones
and valuable reputation was nothing more
than a 100 year old parlor trick born of
the greed of one company DeBeers group
the largest diamond mining company in
the world which is completely
manufactured both the worth of diamonds
and the demand for them I had no idea
that the beers monopolistic policies put
in place more than a century ago enabled
a band of ruthless killers to wrest
diamonds from the heart of an untamed
jungle and sell them to willing buyers
with connects
is to respectable diamond centers from
London to Antwerp to Bombay I didn't
know that the proceeds from diamond
sales funded not only the our ufs war
against its government but also
Hezbollah terrorism against Israel and
al-qaeda attacks against the United
States nor could I have imagined that I
would discover such a complicated and
far-reaching network of smugglers Gun
Runners terrorists corporate
manipulators and corrupt governments
that made such sales possible and I
certainly had no idea that the jewelry
worn by hundreds of thousands of people
around the world was brought at the
expense of innocent and mutilated
Africans who will never be able to wear
jewelry of their own I went to Sierra
Leone to see for myself how the trade
worked to speak with the victims and to
discover how it was possible that the
world's premier symbol of love and
devotion could have been used to fund
one of the most atrocious Wars the 1990s
and I'm going to skip towards the back
of the book I watched United Airlines
flight 175 vaporized into the South
Tower of the World Trade Center while at
the diamond trading company standing
next to an deboned whose corporate cool
evaporated as quickly as the US sense of
security and ebon was the public
relations person who I was speaking with
on September 11th in London it was about
a 15-minute walk back to my East London
hotel but I had no television in my room
I headed to a pub that I knew had
several televisions out on the chilly
streets of London traffic flowed along
as usual and pedestrians streamed by
wearing headphones oblivious to the
attack diamonds were the last things on
my mind or anyone else's for a long time
thereafter I normally watched the
footage over and over people falling a
long way to their deaths from some of
the tallest buildings on earth the
Towers collapsing one after another like
sandcastles the streets of a familiar
city home to dozens of friends and
family members filling with ash and
debris getting on an airplane to Africa
a few days later I felt I was escaping
into the farthest corner of the planet
leaving the chilling cucumber sandwiches
for heat and crushing starvation unaware
that I was actually heading to this one
of the scenes of a global crime now as I
said what makes this story so
fascinating to me is literally every one
of those little aspects of what we have
what I would have said to represent you
here by
the brief part that I read but not just
each individual aspect of that but how
they all literally come together I
remember first hearing about the Sierra
Leone war watching ITN which is a
British cable television news network
it's actually very very good
I live in Longmont we get it on our
public television there late at night
and I remember watching the footage of
just this horrific environment scenes of
people whose hands have been amputated
who were stumbling around with you know
their legs blown off by mortars or
chopped off by axes which is actually
the signature tactic of the
revolutionary united front and I was
thinking myself there's absolutely no
way I would go to a place like this ever
as a journalist because it just seems
like an absolute tragic waste of course
at the time I had no idea the
involvement of diamonds in the entire
thing and once I saw a report I think it
was on 20 20 20 or 60 minutes or one of
the one of those news programs that
actually linked the the war and all
these atrocities that I'd seen in this
horrific environment and this country
that had literally gone down the tubes
in front of everyone's face and just had
become a vacuum of destruction and death
was all caused by diamonds which to me I
almost couldn't make the link in my head
I was thinking diamonds I had no idea
where they came from I really had no
idea what you know that had to do with
it at all is there a cutting industry in
Sierra Leone didn't know so as I found
out a little bit more obviously Sierra
Leone is one of the richest countries it
should be one of the richest countries
certainly its natural resources its
deposits of gold rutile oil bauxite and
especially diamonds is just fantastic it
should be the Saudi Arabia of Africa but
it's not in fact it's one of the poorest
countries in on the planet and the
reason for that is decades and decades
of governmental corruption here you've
heard the same old story before and it's
pretty much the same in Sierra Leone you
know you get a dictator who runs the
country runs the show steals the money
puts it in his pocket ships it off to
Denmark or Copenhagen or where
into his own account that's the kind of
thing that's that occurs in in many
African countries with any natural
resource Nigeria is a really good
example Nigeria should be up among one
of the best places ever to be in terms
of the quality of life how much taxes
should pay for you know beautiful
streets whatnot it's it's a hellhole
it's actually worse than Sierra Leone
and that's because of its oil deposits
and the oiler is more or less stolen and
robbed by the government
same thing with diamonds in Sierra Leone
it's happened for decades
it's just mismanagement and Freetown the
capital of Sierra Leone enjoyed many
modern amenities that's where the seat
of government was that's where you know
the government in the and the dictator
or whomever was the president at the
moment could invest all the money and
you know make fancy buildings and that
kind of thing while ignoring ninety
percent of the rest of the country which
is still to this day living in the dark
ages there's only one 50-mile stretch of
road in all of Sierra Leone out of 7,000
roads that it's actually reasonably
enough paved that you can actually drive
a car on at the speed limit without
having to worry about wrecking it into a
hole or flying off the side of the road
or anything like that so this gave the
revolutionary united front an excuse for
waging its rebellion in the first place
disenfranchisement of something like you
know four and a half million people who
lived in the bush who lived out in these
villages that really haven't changed
very much in the past 50 or 60 years
since before independence concrete
cinder blocks glass that's that kind of
thing is probably the most modern
invention to have made its way so deeply
into the bush as I said a lot of these
roads aren't paved it's it's hell to get
from the modern capital Freetown out to
any of the jungle villages and you know
there is no such thing as you know a
quality educational system access to
medical care so forth so everybody out
there in the bush was living you know
real
Varian is existence kind of a
hand-to-mouth type of thing their
employment was you know catches catch
can is just there's no industry except
for diamonds that was the one big thing
Sierra Leone just got really really
lucky in its geography and that diamonds
and diamond mines and the exact geology
that's required to produce some of the
best gem quality diamonds ever found in
the world have exploded up through the
ground through the jungle and what an
incredible boon this should have been
this should have been one of the best
things to have ever happened to this
country and obviously diamonds are
invaluable in many circumstances they're
priceless several of them are absolutely
beyond value you can buy a carat one
carat diamonds after it's been cut and
polished and set and jewelry for
something like two three thousand
dollars and we're talking hundreds of
thousands of carats of gemstones that
are being literally pulled out of the
ground at you know on a daily basis so
there is no excuse for Sierra Leone not
to have been one of the best places to
visit to live to to be a great place but
because of the mismanagement because of
the colonial infrastructure that really
left the government elect all prepared
to take on the mantle this huge
responsibility of using their natural
resources for the benefit of the
citizens well what it really did was it
turned to turn this the country into a
into sort of a haves and have-nots type
of situation the people who lived in
Freetown the people who were descended
from the colonial ranks and they were a
lot more educated they were a lot more
wealthy and they were a lot kind of
better equipped than anybody else living
in the bush and that that that's
eighty-five to ninety percent of the
entire population of Sierra Leone so in
1991 this you know a revolution was
actually you know ripe for the for the
plucking it was it was absolutely no
question that there was going to be some
sort of armed conflict it just seemed to
occur
almost almost as a natural cause the
revolutionary united front marched right
into Eastern Sierra Leone and started
capturing the diamond districts taking
the diamonds and holding them for ransom
and at first it looked like any other
revolution it looked like you know the
the peasants you know rebelling
literally against against the fiefdom
and the Kingdom over in Freetown and
that's kind of what it was dismissed as
for a very very long time it was just
this bloody small conflict in a nation
of the size of South Carolina in Africa
where there's a civil war every other
day so nobody really wanted to pay any
attention to it nobody cared about it at
all
the truth of the matter is that the ru F
really didn't care about putting in a
better government they didn't want to
necessarily improve the lives of
everybody who was out in the bush they
didn't wanna pay any other streets or
bringing cable television out into the
bush they wanted to take the diamonds
it's a jewelry heist it was just a steal
they just wanted to rob the mines and
sell the diamonds and become personally
rich and that's the way it's been from
91 all the way up until the war ended
just this past January in 2002 so the
question that I had kind of kind of
approaching the story and coming into it
was okay well you know our diamonds are
very valuable but you're you're you know
a bloodthirsty illiterate rebel leader
and you've adopted some battle name like
general bloodbath or something like that
these guys are very creative with the
names that they put on themselves so I
mean how can you sell the diamonds and
that's kind of the point of my book
that's what I wanted to see is how how
were they enabled to become rich how
were they enabled to fund their
insurgency how are they how were they
allowed to do this that's kind of what
it came down to and and that's kind of
what led me into this look at the
diamond industry and looking at the
business of diamonds and how people
market diamonds and how people sell
diamonds and why diamonds are as
expensive as I just described I mean I
think what I said earlier times are
priceless you know everybody knows how
expensive diamonds are they shouldn't be
that way that's the we're
thing about it all diamonds are not as
rare as everybody thinks they are
they're not necessarily the most rare
gem I think emeralds and sapphires as a
matter of fact are less rare than
diamonds and yet they're gigantic ly
less expensive and it all comes down to
this one company De Beers and it's an
amazing creature this this company it's
you can actually make an argument that
it's one of the it's a perfect
corporation because corporations are in
existence for one reason one reason only
to make money to make as much money as
they possibly can and to get away with
as much as humanly possible to make
money laws don't matter morality doesn't
matter it's a corporation it's not a
person so you know the whole role is to
come back as a shareholder you know with
it I'm sorry the whole world is to come
back to please the shareholder so De
Beers was started in 1881 as a result of
this gigantic boom it was just like the
California Gold Rush out here in the
United States
this was the diamond boom of South
Africa and diamonds were discovered in
the 1860s on the banks of the Orange
River down in South Africa and you know
written off as a fluke initially the
only place to anybody found diamonds
prior to this was in India and Brazil so
it's like dead okay diamonds in South
Africa maybe maybe not
people started like literally picking
them out of the riverbank and just
walking around kicking the dirt and
here's a 25 carat stone I mean knowing
the value of that today it's amazing to
think of those days so they had their
own gold rush it was the diamond rush of
South Africa everybody came from
everywhere they were digging every piece
of ground they could find diamonds were
coming up all over the place and within
a couple years South Africa was out
producing Brazil which was up to that
point the world's leading producer of
diamonds three million carats of
diamonds were coming out of South Africa
annually by the 1880s so what this means
anybody who's familiar with a market
economy supply and demand knows that the
more supply that you have the lower the
price is going to be as long as your
demand kind of stays the same so prices
we're going to plummet there
so many diamonds on the market you know
that demand wasn't you know it was where
it was it was stable but the threat was
that there was going to be a giant glut
and the price of diamonds was going to
fall you know through the floor so there
was several people in South Africa who
wanted to avoid that they wanted to buy
as much as they possibly could of the
supply and the person who came out on
top and that never was Cecil Rhodes and
his he's a legendary person he's the
person who's the Rhodes Scholarship is
named after the country of Rhodesia
which is now Zimbabwe and also part
Sambia I think Zimbabwe is in Zambia
yeah the two of those countries used to
be Rhodesia he named it after himself he
also started DeBeers and his whole
policy was to buy as much of the diamond
claims in South Africa as he possibly
could and keep all the diamonds for
himself literally and he was going to
take the diamonds and sell them kind of
as he could here and there
distribute them pretty much just to keep
the flow in line with demand in other
words keep the prices high there's no
excuse for having low prices if you're
in control of the entire supply because
you can just distribute it as you wish
and okay voila you've got you got the
price line but the problem is that you
also need it you need a demand you need
people wanting to buy your diamonds so
what you've got in that circumstances De
Beers suddenly finding themselves in the
position of having to create a demand
for diamonds because diamonds are not
intrinsically valuable at all you can't
do anything with a diamond except cut
other things that are very very hard
diamonds are the hardest substance known
in nature so you know they're great for
you know putting on a saw and being able
to cut steel really quickly or cut other
diamonds that's about as good as it gets
and that characteristic translates into
$30 per carat for an industrial quality
diamond when it comes to luxury however
they're literally invaluable because
everybody here I'm sure anybody in this
room who is married has a diamond or has
bought a diamond one of one or the other
and why is that it's a tradition you
realize you have to buy a diamond for
your bride if you're a bride you expect
a diamond when you when you be engaged
where did that come from it came from De
Beers let me tell you that was that that
was the other part of this game plan
wasn't only controlling the supply but
it was manufacturing a demand for the
product which like I said is worthless
except for its you know very hard
quality so everybody here has heard a
diamond is forever it's one of the most
recognizable marketing slogans in the
history of advertising period and that
it that that goes that goes directly to
De Beers doing nothing but making it
necessary for people who fall in love to
give one another diamonds okay so we've
got the demand side taken care of from
now until forever you're going to have
Brides receiving diamonds from their
husbands no problem there the problem
now is supply because you know naturally
geology being what it is you can't say
for any certainty especially in the
1880s whether or not you have all the
diamond mines in the world you might
have all the ones in South Africa but
you don't have the ones in Brazil you
don't have the ones in India and you
don't have the ones that haven't yet
been discovered so throughout the last
century De Beers has pretty much sat
around and waited for people to discover
diamonds all around the world
and then it has gone in and either
purchased the claim or it has signed
some sort of an agreement so that it
could literally have all the diamonds
coming to it and back in 1881 when De
Beers was incorporated
90% of all diamonds found in the world
went to De Beers and was - and were
distributed through their offices in
London today it's 65 percent it's a
notable decline but you know 65 percent
of the world production of rough
diamonds goes through De Beers hands now
what this means in real terms is that
you have to keep up with where diamonds
are being
found and you have to be willing to buy
them from whomever is selling them and
this is where we get back to Sierra
Leone because the people selling them
are the murderers they're the killers
they're the ones who to date so far have
killed 50,000 to 75,000 innocent
civilians in Sierra Leone and amputated
and util ated another 20,000 and the
market demands that the beers or other
companies outside the De Beers buy these
diamonds and when I say other companies
outside of the beers what I'm talking
about is that the value of diamonds is
now completely established you don't
have to be De Beers you don't have to be
buying the the diamonds from the rebels
and putting it in your stockpile it
doesn't really make any difference who
you are buying the diamonds because the
value is established you're going to be
able to sell them anywhere you want and
you can be able to get this manufactured
worth for them so this is the this is
kind of the dirty secret of the diamond
industry that has never been really
truly aired until 1998 and you know keep
in mind at that at this point the ru F
war has been going on for seven years
we've had people you know amputated
mutilated villages is destroyed and the
world more or less did nothing there was
no call for intervention from Western
countries the United States really had
no involvement whatsoever in Sierra
Leone at the time you have to recall
though that we you know the u.s.
attempted an intervention in Somalia
which went really really badly for
public policy and foreign policy in
terms of I think 18 US soldiers were
killed in Mogadishu and sure many of you
have probably seen and read the book
Black Hawk Down describes it very very
well it's a great book that led to a lot
of people asking questions about what is
the United States doing in the small
bloody post-cold-war
conflicts that really don't threaten the
national interest but they're disturbing
and you know in similar ways Bosnia
suffered suffered exactly the same thing
okay this is this is rough we've got you
know Croatia fighting Serbia in Bosnia
is caught in the middle but you know
there's no national interest so should
the u.s. get involved should we support
a NATO intervention even how should we
look at the UN peacekeeping roles so you
really wide questions in Sierra Leone
when it comes to the map of really what
was happening on a global scale
including Bosnia and Rwanda Sierra Leone
sort of fell by the wayside there was
not much there that set it apart it was
a baffling conflict if you take the
diamond part of it out nobody knew about
this except those inside the diamond
industry and those profiting from it you
know you look at it it just looks like a
senseless worthless waste of life that
nobody would want to get involved with
nobody wants to send their son or
daughter to the Army or the Marines and
have them go suffer and die in a real
hellhole like Sierra Leone that nobody
has ever heard of in the United States
nobody necessarily cares about now what
nobody knew at the time was that many of
the diamonds that they were getting at
Christmas and on anniversaries and in
tennis bracelets and in engagements were
coming from this area and those diamonds
the fact that they were capable of being
sold from Sierra Leone into the
mainstream channels where they were
literally laundered away and sold
through a De Beers style system into the
retail market you could never tell where
the thing came from and there's no
telling if any of you are wearing a
diamond or me I've got a I've got a
diamond ring at home that you know
there's no telling absolutely period
where that diamond came from or who
purchased it who profited from it and
who who basically brought it to the
market and that was kind of the beauty
of the whole thing in turn if you're if
you're the rebels you know that's that's
the great part about it you are have
this wonderful commodity that you can
smuggle away so easily I think I think
the figure I'm going to try to remember
this I think it was 300 grams of
diamonds is equal in value to 40,000
pounds of iron ore and 3,300 grams of
diamonds can fit in the palm of your
hand and you can hide them anywhere on
your body you can swallow them you can
stick them under your tongue
can put them in a cigarette package you
can I could tie it into the ponytail of
my hair here and I can smuggle them and
walk away they don't set off airport
metal detectors and they're untraceable
once you walk away from the scene of the
crime there's nobody who can tell where
it came from after it's been cut before
it's been cut it's almost impossible to
tell where it has come from so it's one
of the most liquid things you can think
of because of this De Beers manufactured
value so you can get rid of diamonds
anywhere Robert Hansen the spy who was
you know worked with the KGB was paid in
diamonds diamonds have this great
history of intrigue as at these
commodities that you know you think of
diamonds and you know you don't
necessarily think of you know shadiness
or anything but there's a little bit of
it you know people your attache cases
full of diamonds you think about you
know that going through going through
airports and nobody knowing you know
what's in the big heel of your shoe that
kind of thing when I went to Sierra
Leone for the first time I was
astonished by the availability of rebel
diamonds I knew all about it I read all
about it I knew that the are UF funded
it's war and had its you know cache of
ak-47s and you know make 26 helicopters
that they used to fight the government
they all came from proceeds and sales of
illegal diamonds but when you get there
you literally walk out onto the street
and you know it's this teeming falling
down broken up shot to hell metropolis
that you know people are walking around
with you know they're they're amputated
there's 20,000 amputees who are living
in Freetown and city of about a million
people now and these guys will come up
to you on the street you know just
whisper to you diamonds do you want
diamonds do you want diamonds and we
were bugged so much because of a
journalist yes clearly I want diamonds I
want to talk to diamond smugglers I want
I want to know all about the business so
you know I ended up at this you know
flea-bitten motel there by the beach and
every day there was a knock on the door
and it was somebody else who had heard
that there was a couple of guys in room
- looking for diamonds and you'd have
guys come in with pistols in their waist
and a bag full of rough goods coming out
of their pocket I mean we're talking I'm
not just talking you know three-quarter
carat carat and a half things that you
know are the most commonly sold
engagement ring in the United States
we're talking five in six and seven and
eight and ten and twelve carat rough
diamonds which you know and a guy with a
with a pistol they're you know
protecting the whole thing and these
guys are everywhere they're in there
rubbin elbows with the United Nations
there's a big UN peacekeeping mission
there they're ubiquitous they are
absolutely everywhere and I mean it just
kind of stunned me to see how you know
blatant they were about everything is
worse than any drug dealer I mean I kind
of imagined I've never been to Colombia
but I assume that I don't even know if I
assume but even in what kind of my comic
book kind of thoughts I don't think when
you get off the plane at the airport you
know there's a bunch of guys you know
offering you cocaine to buy you know big
uncut kilos of coke but I certainly
didn't expect to find out in Sierra
Leone with the Diamonds but that's
exactly the way it was and that's
exactly what I found and the astonishing
thing about that is that I've visited
Sierra Leone in 2001 last summer it's
just about a year ago and the largest UN
peacekeeping mission in history was
deployed in this country this puny
little South Carolina sized country
17,500 UN soldiers I think it was over
well over 600 million dollars per year
spent on this mission which is bigger
than anything that the UN has deployed
and international attention about the
role that diamonds have played in the
entire conflict it's right there
everybody knows about it everybody
especially those involved all the NGOs
and the aid workers and the journalists
it's it's absolutely no question nobody
nobody's wondering you know is there an
ideology are they fighting against the
government no they're fighting for the
diamonds and then to see at the moment
you step foot off the plane it's just
kind of it just kind of blows you away
and the reason is that it's not cocaine
it's not drugs it's not Kimber you know
it's not and there is conflict timber
and that you know that that's comes from
Liberia and hybrid coast but it's
diamonds and diamonds can't have an
incredible value by weight and they're
completely portable you can totally take
them away so you know 98 as I was saying
I diverted here but in 98 that's when a
non-governmental organization called
Global Witness kind of blew the lid off
of you know the role that diamonds have
been playing and this this overall
conflict and suddenly it became a big
kind of head-scratching oh my gosh you
know diamonds have funded this horrible
horrible war which some of the worst
human rights violations have occurred so
okay well we need to do something about
it and you know there's the the typical
bureaucratic wheels get rolling United
States senators you know their their
concern they don't want any of these
conflict diamonds coming from Sierra
Leone or Angola or the Democratic
Republic of Congo to other countries in
which the same situation is occurring
rebels are mining diamonds so you know
they've proposed some laws and over here
the the non-governmental organizations
start lobbying the diamond industry to
do something about it and the diamond
industry here we go again with the you
know perfect corporation all it is
remember is you got to maximize profits
it has to be sensible has to make
economic sense previous to everybody
getting kind of upset about diamonds in
their role in Wars it was easy for the
diamond industry to just say you know
that's just that's not let's look the
other way yeah you know diamonds are
coming from these very questionable
sources from very questionable
salespeople I'd rather not know we'd
rather know Don't Ask Don't Tell I don't
care where it comes from let's just buy
them and stop them in order to keep the
prices high so now suddenly diamonds are
being equated with amputated hands and
that is doing absolutely nothing for the
image of romance and love as you can
imagine and there was serious talk of a
boycott of diamonds you know floating
around about a year or two ago because
the industry was so willingly buying
these diamonds right off right out of
the hands of killers or the people who
have smuggled them from
click zones and bought them from killers
and it's very easy to see how it was
done it DeBeers didn't have a
representative in Freetown it wasn't out
there in the bush there was nobody
risking getting shot to buy the diamonds
the rebels simply smuggled them to
Liberia which is right next door or
Guinea which is just on the other side
or a little bit further to Ivory Coast
or the Gambia and it's a smoking gun
when you look at the import export
statistics Sierra Leone had a high of I
think was 2 million carats a year in the
late 1960s when they were exporting
diamonds and it was a legitimate
industry the surrounding countries did
not have nearly as much there's much
more modest mines and maybe a couple
hundred thousand carats a year suddenly
with UN sanctions being placed on
exporting any diamonds from Sierra Leone
meaning it's illegal for anybody to buy
diamonds from Sierra Leone and export
them how to Europe where they were cut
and polished every other country that
had never seen any any any type of
export numbers to be very proud of
suddenly started seeing these volumes of
diamonds being exported out into Europe
that absolutely unexplainable other than
that they're smuggled from Sierra Leone
so and that's kind of how it all
happened so uh the long and short of
that is that I'm just I'm trying to I'm
trying to kind of paint the picture of
the diamonds were yeah I was it was a
problem and it was mainly a problem for
the diamond industry and the people who
are buying diamonds but it was
manageable because the diamond industry
kind of did a quick 180 and said ok well
suddenly absolutely we're not buying any
diamonds from anywhere that are even
remotely questionable we're all for
sanctions we're all for some sort of a
certification process let's come up with
a regimen to you know ensure that
there's a paper trail for every diamond
that's sold anywhere in the world and
there's not going to be anything from
any rebel groups it's all going to
become from absolutely legitimate
sources so it was kind of you know it's
pretty good in terms of you know the
diamond industry handling it and the
international community being pleased
with how the diamond industry
handling it and and then September 11th
occurred and I was I was I was literally
at De Beers I was talking I was talking
with the De Beers representatives when
when this tragic incident occurred and I
remembered my interview was interrupted
by a guard he came in and said excuse me
aren't you from the United States I said
yeah and he was like a plane crashed
into the World Trade Center this is run
just the first plane had crashed and I
was of course like everybody else
thinking it was a Cessna a small plane a
glider or something like that so I
didn't really even think about it
and the De Beers guy said well let's
turn the TV on and just check it out and
so you know he clicked it on and we
watched the second plane crash right
into the other Tower and instantly
obviously I will along with everyone
else in the world what I was doing at
that moment talking about diamonds in
Sierra Leone and conflicts went totally
out the window I didn't care about it
didn't care at all I just cared about
getting in touch with my relatives and
my friends and make sure everybody was
okay and you know mainly getting my head
around what had occurred but the truth
is that leading up to September 11th al
Qaeda had taken advantage of the United
States the Western world the United
Nations all of these responsible global
policing organizations their disdain for
getting involved in Sierra Leone
like I said Sierra Leone was a bloody
little mess nobody wanted to get
involved the diamond issue was being
taken care of by the diamond industry so
there was no call whatsoever for you
know big intervention there was a UN
mission on the books that wasn't
deployed until 99 but back in 1998 al
Qaeda had started buying diamonds from
Sierra Leone rebels and they were
laundering millions of dollars through
these diamonds and taking the goods and
just holding on to them because they
know the value that diamonds maintain
they know that you could sell them
anywhere they know there's no telling
where they're from and they know that
you can get rid of them really quickly
and make probably a really really good
profit one of the beautiful things if
you're in the business of smuggling
illegal diamonds when the beautiful
things about rebel diamonds is that
they're extremely cheap
the rebels don't necessarily have you
know a big marketing clout they can't
exactly go shop around for the best
price so they're willing to let these
rough diamonds go for 10% of what they
would normally be worth under any other
circumstance so legitimate smugglers
people who work for legitimate diamond
houses and I met a number of them they
were staying in my hotel in the room
right next to me I had dinner with
several of them had flown down from
Europe and were there to buy rebel
diamonds because they were cheap and
because they could make an incredible
profit off of them so what we have now
is al-qaeda buying diamonds from as
early as 1998 all the way up until
September 11th probably which the tragic
part of this is like I said there was
the largest UN mission was right there
in the heart of Sierra Leone supposedly
deployed throughout the country and
supposedly enforcing a mining banned by
the rebels but didn't happen the rebels
were just mining right under the noses
of the United Nations and I mean I guess
maybe that's that's clearly points to
one of the reasons I have a pretty low
opinion of most UN peacekeeping missions
but this one in particular so however
that said the UN mission did succeed
after all after after a series of
incredibly disastrous failures to secure
a peace agreement a ceasefire back in
May and it slowly took hold there was
still a lot of mining literally all the
way up until the last minute up until
November and December of this past year
the rebels were still mining diamonds
and peace was finally declared in
January of this year and the way that
most UN missions go that least that I've
the ones that I've literally seen in in
progress one in Bosnian one and Kosovo
and now the one in this in Sierra Leone
you get a peace agreement and as soon as
all the weapons are accounted for at
least most of them yet hold an election
and kind of keep your fingers crossed
and hope for the best
that seemed
to be the whole mode of operation for
most UN peacekeeping missions this one
actually seemed to work may 14th was was
the first democratic elections since
1996 when there was a just a disastrous
meltdown the ru F ran over the entire
country and but fortunately it didn't
happen this time everybody was really
expecting some sort of violence myself
included I didn't think it was going to
be nearly as peaceful or free and fair
as it as it turned out to be but it has
been and it's been all quiet on Sierra
Leone's front so to speak and that right
there has done more to end this trade in
conflict diamonds than any of these
little certification regimens which
simply don't you can't account for every
single stone I mean these things are
puny they're pebbles this is a six
billion dollar a year industry involving
pebbles and there's no way that you can
account for each and every pebble that
trades hands through dozens of borders
dozens of times and back rooms and shady
bars and you know strange deals and you
can't produce a certificate you cannot
have a paper trail about where all those
diamonds went and so there is no way to
tell with any certainty that the diamond
that you're buying on any daily basis
has or has not come from a conflict zone
there's simply no way to do it even if
it comes with a certificate even if it
comes with somebody's guarantee or an
affidavit or a word of honor or whatever
the case is because that person might
not be able to tell nobody can tell
unless you physically see it mind and
you physically walk away with it the
only diamond I would feel absolutely
comfortable buying that I knew didn't
come from a rebel group that was using
the proceeds to buy weapons and to
continue to kill and terrorize was the
one that I saw mine die in Sierra Leone
I saw a legitimately mined government
leave government licensed miner pull a
diamond out of the ground and if he'd
sold that to me just then in there and
it will only cost five bucks I think it
was about it was about a carat and a
half or no is a quarter carat quarter
carat diamond for five dollars because
that's what he was going to get for it
from the guy he was supposed to sell it
to I would take that now it's the only
one I would actually feel perfectly
positively
secur about because I saw it mind now
the diamond industry has a really good
point in terms of how many diamonds were
talking about that are mined by rebel
groups and how many county could be
tainted we're talking about maybe four
or five percent of the global output
which sounds reassuringly small I mean I
when I heard that I was like okay well
it's actually not that big of a problem
in that case however you're talking the
value on that three or four percent or
five percent you know there's a lot of
debate the value on that has led to
millions of deaths and displacements and
literally the destruction of at least
three countries based over a war on
natural war natural resources so that
kind of to me anyway is is a very Boop
it doesn't matter to me that it's only
three or four percent the way to make
sure that this industry is squeaky clean
is to maybe take a look at foreign
policy and foreign policy changes in
terms of how we deal with these small
conflicts that don't seem to have
anything to do with our national
interest and Sierra Luna is just a
perfect example of how little remote
conflicts that don't seem to have
anything to do with with us actually end
up having everything to do with us
everyone is going to remember September
11th and everyone is going to be
remembering exactly where they were and
you're going to recall the couple of
weeks immediately after the attacks in
which the United States and its European
allies froze assets of al Qaeda all
across the world and tied up 100 million
dollars of al Qaeda funds in like three
and a half weeks you know a pretty
amazing amount of time and a pretty
amazing amount of money but that does
nothing to account for the several
millions of dollars of worth of diamonds
that somebody has somewhere that they
can turn into cash like that and use to
continue these attacks against the
United States
ah so with that I'm going to
taking the much-needed deep breath I
would be more than happy I went on a
whole lot longer than I should as I
apologize I'm going to go ahead and
entertain it as many questions as we
like I'm going to ask you to wait just a
minute until the boom microphone
actually comes in front of your face
before you actually speak up and ask
your question in that way we can make
sure it's going to be heard by everybody
so sir two questions one does your book
document the al-qaida connection m2 as
any US intelligence agency been
interested or shown any interest in your
research good two good questions and I
think I'm going to I'm going to nullify
the second one by answering the first
one I wish I could take credit for
having done original research on the al
Qaeda connection however that was done
by a colleague of mine named Doug Farah
who is the Washington Post bureau chief
for West Africa and Doug and I have
actually never met the guy but we seem
to kind of follow in each other's
footsteps here and there he's always a
couple of steps ahead of me here a
couple steps enemy there we've traded
emails and talked on the phone quite a
bit and Doug's story came out on
November 2nd 2001 and I treat him in the
book as a character when one of the many
characters that I see and I was more
than happy to give him all the
well-deserved credit that that he
deserves for breaking that story more or
less wide open so there's an entire
chapter on that and Doug actually got a
lot of his information as as far as I
understand him from what he told me he
got his information from intelligence
agencies as well so they're already well
aware of it sure
yes ma'am hold on one wait for the
microphone
am i there yes good what do you see as
the answer to solving this problem well
that's that was one of the big things I
wanted to ask myself because it is so
frustrating right now the the solution
that's on the table is you may have
heard the term the Kimberley Process if
you followed this the Kimberley Process
is it's a name for an organization of
non-governmental organizations diamond
industry representatives and
governmental officials for diamond
producing countries and what they've
done is they've gotten together they've
had roundtable discussions and they're
tackling the issue of how do we stop the
trade in blood diamonds the answer you
know they've batted around a lot of
things should we brand the lasers
on-site where they're found or brand the
right brand the diamonds with lasers oil
at the places where they're found that's
probably not workable because once you
cut and polish the diamond you're going
to lose the identifying mark so you're
not going to be able to know for sure
again which mine it came from mass
spectometry
exactly what impurities chemical and
mineral impurities are in each diamond
that is being sold can you match that to
a mine somewhere in the world again you
know data collection how you're going to
get around that so what was proposed and
the Kimberley process was you know I
would want to say stalled they were
making process but really slow going
until September 11th and suddenly the
al-qaeda connection with Sierra Leone's
diamonds came about and suddenly the
Kimberley Process came up with a
recommendation just like that and the
recommendation was a certification
process whereby every diamond that is
discovered anywhere in the world is
recorded on unforgeable paper and then
it's forwarded on with the diamond to
the next person and the next person
records it they make a receipt so it's
this big long paper trail that goes from
the mine to the miner to the broker to
the merchant to the exporter to the
cutting house to the guy who buys it to
Tom Shane's people who
to the realtor or the retail place here
in the mall and then finally to you so
you look at this thing and it says it's
been through everybody's hanging all
four hundred and fifty five people or
however many because literally it can go
through that many hands however the big
however is how are you going to ensure
that this happens how are you going to
ensure that in especially in third-world
countries the places poorest Sierra
Leone where customs officials the figure
I was told was unbelievable I think it
was customs officials in Sierra Leone
make per month what a minimum wage
employee makes every day here in the
United States and so we're you're
talking hundreds of thousands of dollars
and millions of dollars online in terms
of smuggling so you know the smuggler
who wants to get rid of the rebel
diamonds is just can say you know hey
pal here's a hundred dollars right as a
certificate it's not it's not actually
at all out of the realm of possibility
the other thing is that you know mixing
in rebel goods because they're so cheap
mixing them into legitimate licensed
parcels so easy because like I said
these things are they're tiny they're
small it's not like a drum of oil or a
rift of timber or whatever whatever l or
iron or anything else you might be
selling these things are totally
portable totally small and if you have a
package that's been valuated and sealed
and taxed and stamped and it's clean and
it's good to go and you open it up and
to throw in your handful of rebel
diamonds that you got mix it all in
there that license covers those two so
in terms of a bureaucratic solution I
don't think there is one I mean that's
that's my kind of honest assessment of
the situation I really think that the
only way to address conflict diamonds is
to in the conflicts where diamonds are
found that seems to be the best way
Sierra Leone has dealt with its problem
because now there is no such thing as
conflict diamonds from Sierra Leone
there are UF doesn't exist there's going
to be smugglers all the time the people
are going to smuggle across across from
one border to the other to get rid of
you know taxing problems or there we go
high taxes in one place get rid of them
over here or just smuggle them out so
they can get as much profit as possible
but if you don't have a
conflict you don't have a conflict
diamond you don't have people selling
the diamonds for weapons and using those
weapons to continue terrorizing the
civilians and stealing the diamonds and
kind of keeping the cycle going so I
guess I mean I don't have now don't ask
me how to end the conflicts I mean that
that's that that has to do with you know
a lot of foreign policy the United
Nations and it's it's kind of
self-appointed role as global
peacekeeper you know there's a there's a
lot of debate going ice completely in
flux the the model that is in place now
it seems to be just simple a simple
knee-jerk to anything that's troubling
and disturbing you know a bad conflict
somewhere that is there's bad human
rights violations and there's no clear
good guy or bad guy the UN goes in and
the mode of operation seems to be secure
a peace deal at all costs whether or not
anybody agrees with it you know the
people who are actually fighting that's
what we saw in Kosovo between the KLA
and the Serbs Madeleine Albright came in
and negotiated an agreement that neither
side was necessarily very happy with the
same thing with the peace agreement that
kind of was touted as the end of the war
in Sierra Leone it was a agreement
called the LeMay Accords in 1999 the ru
F and the government's yeah they liked
it they agreed to it but it was a it was
not tenable it simply wasn't workable at
all and then you send in your
peacekeeping force so you've got your
troops from all over the place and it
can it can be a farce it's ridiculous in
Sierra Leone great example the moment
the the force deployed with an original
force of I think it was 260 monitors and
6,000 soldiers into a conflict zone
involving upwards of 50,000 drugged and
illiterate two armed teenagers who
really didn't want to have anything
really to do with peace and what
happened 500 UN soldiers were were
captured and held prisoner as a complete
mockery and two other humiliation to the
organization and and it's only slightly
gotten better I was when I was in Sierra
Leone I was there
in this is a trip I took in July last
year the United Nations mission was two
years old and I keep saying the size of
the countries the size of South Carolina
and I used to live in the south and you
could drive from one end in South
Carolina to the other in a day after two
years the UN had not fully deployed to
all areas of the country because they
were too outgunned they were too nervous
they were too disorganized their member
countries that were being you know where
you get the soldiers from you got guys
from no offense to any of them but
they're completely variously disciplined
you've got Jordanian soldiers you know
neck and neck with Zambian soldiers
right next to the Egyptian soldiers and
nobody knows who's the boss they get ten
different languages going on and it's it
was a disaster it still was I got stuck
with the ghanians and bless their hearts
are all really nice people I mean I
really enjoyed their hospitality in
terms of how nice they were but they had
no organizational skill whatsoever we
were supposed to go to this we were
going to be joined a vanguard of UN
soldiers who finally you know that
criticism had gotten high enough that
all right you guys have to fear you're
supposedly disarming this country and
bringing peace to it it'd be nice if you
were everywhere so they're okay we're
going to go in this long-range patrol
and so I was hooked up with a bunch of
other journalists and went off with them
and ended up nearly starving for four
days and wound up more or less you know
a prisoner with them with the 200
Ghanian soldiers of the are you f is
simply because they kind of didn't know
what they were doing and it was it was
just a disaster and I outlined that
whole experience and one of the last
chapters of the book here so I don't
know exactly what what to tell you in
terms of actually ending the conflict
yes you speak with such authority about
how these diamonds are smuggled or
carted out of a nation I was curious if
you ever tried to purchase for research
purposes only any diamonds from the
street how that turned out
tried and that that's a good way to put
it in fact I did my goal once I got
there was to actually see how easy it
was to smuggle so I became a smuggler I
wanted I wanted to do this
I wanted to buy a diamond from the Ru F
and smuggle it out of the country and
then attempt to sell it in the United
States once I got here with full
disclosure of where I had gotten it from
and the main reason for my research was
because I'd heard so much from the
diamond industry about how it just
doesn't happen nobody's going to get
risk getting caught with a with a rebel
diamond because you know just it you
know nobody wants their hands tainted
nobody everyone wants to wash their
hands nobody wants the blood from the
diamonds to wash off on them and Oh as a
footnote I was going to contribute the
money that I would have made from the
from the sale to Doctors Without Borders
which runs a camp for amputees and war
wounded in Freetown so I did I did the
time I met with I met with dozens of
diamond smugglers looked in it I looked
at and evaluated dozens and dozens and
dozens of stones you know big small
whatnot and didn't have a lot of money
to spend so I was trying to get
something for $100 and wound up getting
scammed that in the end I bought a about
the most expensive piece of safety glass
that has ever been smuggled out of
Sierra Leone
and I was so disappointed - so yes sir
I'm mins for weapons in the past I was
wondering what were some of the major
countries they're getting the weapons
from because I know some of the small
arms are really a weapon of mass
destruction as well oh yeah great
question by the way um met most of the
weapons have come from Eastern European
countries from Bulgaria Romania and
Ukraine and the United Nations has taken
a very long hard look at exactly how
weapons get from their manufacturing
plants in Eastern Europe to the jungles
because there are no are no ak-47
factories in the jungle and Syria
anywhere in West Africa for that matter
at least that I know of and the ru f was
buying Stinger missiles you know very
high-tech weaponry RPG rocket-propelled
grenades and tubes ammunition in million
block orders 12.7 millimeter browning
heavy machine guns which are you know
the size of this stage that need to be
bolted down into a truck or on the
ground before they could be fired
anti-aircraft weaponry landmines the
ubiquitous ak-47 ak-47 from Liberia just
a massive an Army's worth of of stuff
and there they relied on not just the
country you don't necessarily go you
know ring up a manufacturer somewhere in
the country you have to rely on a very
sympathetic government and very corrupt
government and in this case next door to
Sierra Leone Liberia is run by President
Charles Taylor who was very close to the
are UF to the rebels in Sierra Leone he
trained with Foday Sankoh who is the
leader of the r UF he trained in the art
of guerrilla warfare up in libya back in
the late 1980s and he launched his
rebellion in 89 captured the government
in i want to say 91 overthrew the
government of Samuel Doe and became one
of the most despotic people literally
still in power he's still the president
and he wanted a big cut of Sierra
Leone's diamond
it's as simple as that and his friend
and colleague who he trained with Foday
Sankoh leader of the ru f he made a deal
he said you know you go on in there and
capture the diamond mines and bring the
diamonds out back through Liberia give
me a good percentage and I'm going to
facilitate the weapons transactions and
the way that happens is that there's one
guys he's a real character almost out of
a comic book he's a former KGB agent who
was born in Tajikistan who speaks seven
or eight languages who was a fighter
pilot in the Russian Air Force who now
runs a network of gun-running airline
services all throughout Africa and the
Middle East his name is Viktor Bout
known very well to intelligence agencies
the CIA mi5 and he's also suspected of
supplying the Taliban in Afghanistan and
al-qaeda with weaponry leading up to the
days before September 11th because they
anticipated an attack from the United
States in retaliation for the attack he
also supplied weapons to Sierra Leone
and the rebels there and the rebels in
Angola and the rebels in the DRC
Democratic Republic of Congo and it was
just purely a diamonds for weapons
transaction and you had to facilitate it
Charles Taylor the president Liberia
would make a phone call to his friend
the president and the defense minister
in Burkina Faso for instance another
country just the north of Liberia and he
would ask them to place an order and the
order would be for four thousand ak-47s
a half a dozen 12.7 s and then a billion
rounds of ammunition and plus helicopter
parts you know spare rotors or whatever
you might need
so the burkina faso government would
actually place the order from ukraine
for instance and ukrainians would fill
the order and ship it to burkina faso
thinking it was just going to remain
there president Taylor would send Viktor
Bout helicopters to Burkina Faso to pick
up the weapons and fly them right back
down to Monrovia the capital liberia
they get on timber trucks and the trucks
would go to the border of Sierra Leone
and human mules would pick them up and
walk them back to the soldiers in the
bush and every step along the way the
guys who owned the trucks the guys who
hit the plane
hangers at the airport the guys who
signed off on the end-user certificate
in burkina faso - the guy who flew the
plane you name it they all got a cut of
the diamond money hello okay good I'm
sorry
quick follow-up and then can we do one
more after he's follow okay thanks
and where did the government of Sierra
Leone get their weapons from they didn't
get them from Eastern Europe i get i
would imagine maybe some of the western
countries got supplied their weapons yes
and no there are a number of like
watershed moments throughout the history
i'll make this really quick i promise
number of watershed moments about the
history of sierra leone in which one
sanction was put down and then another
sanction was put down regarding arms
embargoes and whatnot the government of
Sierra Leone used largely the same
tactics they bought their weapons with
diamonds also in kind of a strange way
they had they didn't have diamonds
themselves because the rebels controlled
the diamond fields and therefore the
physical diamonds but the government had
the legal right to grant diamond mining
concessions so in other words you could
go to a mercenary corporation which is
what they did back in I think it was
1996-97 they hired this company called
executive outcomes in South Africa which
is a private military you can you can
order the up their services and two
hundred men and attack helicopters and
reconnaissance and satellite infrared
photos and you name it but it's going to
be extremely expensive and most
companies most governments that
executive outcomes works for are in kind
of the same position as the Sierra Leone
government they're illegal entity but
they don't have any money they're
bankrupt they're broke but they do have
the legal right to give away the diamond
mining concessions so through a lot of
kind of shady you know backroom
handshake deals executive outcomes and
other companies like if there's just one
example
they've got deals with diamond
exploration companies oil exploration
companies other natural resource
extraction companies they're capable of
you know coming it's war bounty is kind
of what it comes down to you know you
hire this company to come in and wipe
out the rebels and you know win back the
diamond
Mines and you're entitled to a
percentage of the diamonds that come out
of there okay
one hold on hold on just one second this
was wait till we get there
I'm just wondering about your comments
about the United Nations and so forth
and wondering whether peace would have
come without this further publicity it's
over given all the problems of UN has
what's better would peace have come
without the publicity from the conflict
ends is what you're asking okay you know
it's it's kind of hard to say there were
there were several times over the past
maybe four or five years where it seemed
like peace was at its doorstep at Sierra
Leone's doorstep and the perfect example
is the LeMay Accords that I referred to
earlier this was a peace agreement that
was the United Nations kind of brokered
this agreement between the rebels in the
government and and the UN and part of
the provision of the peace agreement was
that a UN peacekeeping force would enter
the country but this came in the wake
just a couple of months after one of the
worst assaults that the rebels had ever
deployed against the citizens against
the civilians of Sierra Leone and it was
an attack on the capital on Freetown
that was codenamed operation no living
thing so it was self-explanatory and
they they fulfilled you know the name of
the six thousand people were killed in
like a I think a week and they're mostly
civilians and people's countless number
of people were just amputated and
tortured and summarily executed the
whole list of human rights violations so
in the wake of that the West finally
kind of woke up and said all right the
bloodshed is numbing we have to do
something about this
so they came down and negotiated this
peace agreement which you know to me was
laughable it it allowed the leaders of
the revolutionary and I for the rebels
to be installed in government posts
without having to be elected
Fotis anko the leader of the rebels was
appointed vice president under a man he
had al stood in a coup two years before
and he was also put in charge of the
government post that oversees diamond
production so he basically won what he
wanted which is control of the diamonds
and the rebels were to be given amnesty
for all war crimes committed up to that
point
and this is in a country where they
invented their own war crime there was
no such thing as amputation of civilians
on a mass scale like there was with the
ru f
and so it was everything the cake in
them eating it - for the rebels it was
as good as it could possibly get and
they still weren't happy enough with it
that as soon as the UN contingent
deployed they took 500 of them hostages
the war just kept on going until you
know delicate negotiation so the the
LeMay accords is more or less rendered
you know completely ineffectual now and
none of those provisions are true the
the leader of the rebels is in jail
awaiting trial for murder and there is a
war crimes component to the to the UN
peacekeeping mission which is actually
going to start taking place very shortly
so thank you for enduring me I really
appreciate
thank you good sounds okay Greg
Campbell's book blood diamonds is
published by West View press online at
Westview press calm